[Music]
greetings from Kyoto a very rainy
morning right now I'm with the all-new
Sony zv1 Mark II now I'm going to be
spending the next few days in Kyoto been
walking around we're trying food we're
going to sites we're going to be
obviously in better weather than right
now but I want to give you an aspect of
what this camera is like and what are
the differences that we're seeing from
the original zb1 that came out a couple
years ago till today first and foremost
a wider angle lens 18 to 50 percent at
24 that starting point which was a
little bit too close if you won the Vlog
18 is that sweet spot and I'm glad that
they have implemented this also we've
got directional mics on this so you can
actually have to unlike pointed directly
to the person talking if you want to do
a product showcase where you're shooting
a product and you're going to talk
behind it you can set it that way or
also can go automatically detect where
the voices are coming from so I actually
have it set now to me you talking
directly to the camera got a dead cat on
it as well USBC charging for this uh the
battery is swappable with the grip
underneath it's on the grip is on the
side of the camera now versus underneath
it and we've got City mode which I'm
recording it right now this is a 2.35
aspect ratio and you can record in 24 or
25 E4 pal turns out there like ourselves
in Asia and you can obviously set this
at 1.8 put the ND filter on you're going
to get much more of a cinematic look as
you're seeing right now and you can
change the colors on that but I keep it
a classic because to me that looks the
best you've got that fantastic Sony eye
tracking available right now
everything's locked onto me perfectly
the stabilization seems to be pretty
good and I think the audio sounds really
good as well plus it's all touch enabled
on the display so you can actually
control your camera through the touch
display for the most part and the new
Sony menu system these are some of the
new attributes that are part of the zv1
Mark II and by the way if you want to
see what it looks like without the city
mode on this is what it looks like so
you remove that black bar on the top and
bottom to get more of that wider shot
that 18 millimeter is coming into play
right now how gorgeous how beautiful is
this angle this is exactly what the zv1
needed from the beginning we have it in
the Mark II all right now let's go check
out Kyoto this this video is brought to
you by MSI meet the summit E6 and flip
in Flint the latest 12th gen Intel Core
i7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and
a 16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime alright so now we
are having some what is it called uni
rice rice
and I just have some salmon
[Music]
yeah
she likes Zuni it's going to date
this camera's pretty good for food
vlogging so what we're trying to do
that's what we're doing now that's what
we're doing now we're testing out the
camera here and um
[Music]
so now we're gonna go outside and this
is where I'm gonna test the ND uh option
inside this camera to see how it
performs so uh what I will be doing here
I'm recording without the ND we go
outside I'm in manual mode so we're
going to see the difference on this it's
going to get pretty bright here right
now
very very bright
now the nd's on much much better
especially when you're outside at 1.8
aperture one over 60 and it's much much
better exposed now obviously this will
only do so well it's kind of a slightly
overcast day I mean a little bit of blue
skies but clouds covering it so it is a
bit brighter so I may need to create uh
crank up the shutter speed a bit
unfortunately but we got to do what we
got to do right there we have it we're
still 1.8 1 over 80 and this nd's
looking pretty good A little bit
Overexposed what do you think how's the
image quality okay
a little bit bright right there we go
let's bring it back down
let's bring to 125 here
100 that's that 100 looks pretty good
right now that's it so this is what
we're looking like right now
Colonel Sanders there he is
personally I like the Cinematic mode
nice little black bars on top and bottom
I have no idea how this would look on
YouTube yet because I haven't put
anything up on it so far but it does
give it a much more cinematic look if
you will and we obviously weren't
classic color you can go odd it's a good
difference fresh
we got fresh look a little bit odd on
that chic
[Music]
I look like I'm Edward Cullen from
Twilight gotta run over exposed one of
the two
mono
I was gonna see what classic classic
works for me classic works for me
all right I bet classic works yeah I'm
on auto for the microphones it's picking
everything around me
so if I go directional now it's on
direction for me right here so we got to
keep walking either Shake Shack should
we try Shake Shack since we're in Kyoto
no I don't think so I mean we have that
in Singapore why would we do it here in
Kyoto we want Seafood we want beef oh
baby beef we want the good stuff we want
soba too actually we haven't had silver
yet but then again we've only been here
for a day
[Music]
thank you
all right now we are at The kasuga
Shrine as I kind of watch you guys
through the specs earlier about what's
new with this camera you're actually
going to see what it's like to you know
just day-to-day usage obviously we're
within a Shiki Market as well so you get
to see a little bit of food vlogging ND
filter coming into play we're also doing
that right now here's tucked in the
background right there
it's been a long day
but I gotta tell you this camera is
definitely improved I gotta watch look
over a deer poop there's a lot of deer
poop here
look at the shrine here
the entrance but uh
yeah this camera's definitely improved
over the original the microphones in
terms in terms of the directional aspect
of equal automatic or you can actually
just set it how you want it like I have
to sit to me going front here with the
dead cat and it's good the audio is much
better I think than the previous one
having 18 millimeters definitely helps
when you're vlogging I'm on that Cinema
mode right now as well so I prefer that
1.8 locked in
and I'm good to go of course you have
the product showcase and portrait
background and all that kind of stuff
but this camera is definitely one I
would definitely want to put in the
Arsenal actually well let's try the mic
let's go from behind
and see how that goes so now I'm talking
to you guys from behind the mic and are
these I don't know these are lanterns or
sort of monuments of sorts deer are a
sacred animal here so you see deer
walking around as you can see right
there there's roaming around people can
feed them you can get uh some treats for
them that are approved to be sold so
yeah they're very funny
it's uh very cute I've never been in
close to a deer before like that how
cool is that
this is
[Music]
yeah
all right so I am now in
the Tory Gates of Fushimi nari we are
here walking through in fact I was
looking for a great place to shoot
anyway we look tired today we were up
super early we thought we would beat
their crowd unfortunately that didn't
happen we got here about 7 A.M and there
were still a lot of people so if you're
reading online you're thinking yourself
hey I'm gonna get here super early and
beat the crowd you're not anyway
um this is where I kind of right now
here inside the gates and uh yeah we're
gonna head off into the bamboo forest
right now
[Music]
all right
culture
the more slipping noise you make the
better it is so
slurp away
trying a little bit product showcase
here
very nice
that's it
I think I did that wrong
[Music]
okay we're gonna try with the soup soup
it's hot wait wait before you do that
you want to show the cup to the camera
what does it look like service let's try
it
between this
Silva and the river
and this is the river by the way
we are at arushiyama which is where the
bamboo forest is at so we haven't gone
to the bamboo course yet they're going
to try to go it's a little bit open
overcast today yesterday was really
really hot when we went to um
yeah so we're gonna see what that's like
and uh maybe see some damn before so we
actually saw some at the was it
furoshima put a shot
dinari Shrine yeah so we saw some
bamboos there but that bamboo of course
there was a very small one hidden the
secret band before so this one is the
big one this is the one that everybody
talks about so off we go and we'll show
you some shots over there all right now
we are in the arashimaya bamboo forest
absolutely stunning
and this is what it looks like here
going all the way up
gotta look up always look up it's
actually more beautiful when you look up
as you get into the bamboo forest
the temperature really drops a bit it
does
air con it's not like Singapore where
we're just sweating imagine being like
this in Singapore we would be sweating
like crazy
all right we're wrapping up this uh
review of sorts actually kind of a it's
an evolutionary product not a
revolutionary product they've improved a
lot of the things people had an issue
with with original zb1 this is going to
be one of your favorite vlogging cameras
out there even if you just want to take
you know just a nice travel camera
Stills you want to you know capture
yourself eating food and going places
The Wider lens at 18 millimeters at 50
is going to serve a lot of people much
better than the original one also the
improved mics on this the cine mode on
this version this is a really really
good camera system I have to say they've
improved what they need to improve and
um I'm enjoying it I am really enjoying
it and I wasn't a huge fan of the zv1 I
thought it was okay but this is
something that would definitely keep in
my bag in my personal opinion anyway
those are my thoughts on the all-new zb1
Mark II let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below if you like this
video check out more of our camera